Bobby is with us in Raleigh North
Carolina hi Bobby what your net worth
oh it is 4.6 million good for you and
break that down for me how's that broken
out you're probably not gonna like this
but I've got 1.5 million in cash in the
bank's real estate 1.4 and investments
around 1.7 million okay I'm not gonna
argue with the guy with the 4.6 million
dollar net worth if he's got some tag
sitting around so you're heavy in cash
but that's a that so 1.7 is in
investments mutual footers okay all
right cool how old are you I'm 53 okay
cool and how much of this 4.6 is there
because you inherited it not a penny
zero I created it at all
not you and what has been your career
field and your working lifetime I was
with a supermarket chain for 22 years
left that and opened up a real estate
company been doing that for about 23
years now okay so real estate and
supermarket on it cool what's your
degree in do not have a degree okay and
got you and what has been the range of
your income like your worst household
income here and your best household
income here over your what 25 30 years
of working oh well you want me to
include the supermarket on that yeah
okay I'd say probably the worst 32,000
mm-hmm the best 450 3,000 good for you
okay so Real Estate's been very very
good to you yes sir
yeah I've been good to it yeah well you
hone a bunch of it how much of the 1.4
is in your home my just my own home
probably about mmm probably about
550,000 okay so you got close to a
million an investment property then and
that mate that alone would make you a
millionaire something like that so what
advice would you give the 25 year old
version of you
well for me I'd say stay away from the
credit cards I got in bad trouble with
credit cards when I was about 21 and I
had to consolidate everything and make
payments for five years once a month and
that broke me from using credit cards I
still use them but I pay it off every
month also one thing I did and I learned
this a long time ago write your goals
down what your goals are and I actually
taped them to my bathroom mirror so I
can see them where did you make them in
where did that's awesome where did you
make the most of your money real estate
okay yeah and so how much of that is
there because you borrowed money you
borrow money do those real estate deals
I did not borrow a penny you bought at
all cash look at you yes Wow I love it
very cool yeah and so you bet you are
you you are you a real estate broker as
well is that what you do for a living
I am own a real estate company and I've
got 28 people that work for me awesome
look at you way to go how many
non-fiction books do you read in a year
maybe one or two okay what's the most
important book you've read not one of
mine in the last five years last five
years most important books well a game
change that's a political biography but
I enjoyed it okay very cool good job
well done Bobby
4.6 man awesome love it love it love
talking to people who are winning yeah I
can be done out there guys it can be
done
and so far nobody's inherited their
money so far no one stole their money so
far none of them are world-class
athletes most of them don't have high
GPAs mm-hmm
maybe regular people can do this if they
did the right stuff this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]